the concept of heroes having an enemy
with similar powers is pretty common
flash had reverse flash spider-man had
venom hell
even goku had goku black which i guess
it was someone else
in his own exact body but still i mean
it counts
a villain using the power of a hero
always gets our interest
partly because it provides a glimpse as
to what the good guy
would look like if they turn bad in my
here academia
le million was stated to be ua's top
student and the closest to being the
number one hero according to the
wise words of professor izawa thanks to
senaita's prediction
we know that mirio's hero days will
eventually return which completely ruin
my chances of making a convincing theory
about mirio turning evil what i can do
though is i can ask
how things would have turned out if
lomilian was a villain
from the very start this video generally
does avoid spoilers
with one exception and it relates to the
past of kiragiri
that is really the only spoiler of any
significance in this video
but do proceed with caution in this
series we've seen how villains are
largely a product of their environment
this is especially obvious for
characters like gentle criminal but you
could arguably say the same for many of
our main castes
for example murio nearly drowned as a
young boy
but was saved by this unnamed hero who
he then went on to idolize
the act of being saved by this hero is
what created myrio's drive to save a
million people
hence the design on the front of his
outfit and his hero name as well
such an origin story could easily be
contrasted with shigeraki being saved by
the villainous all for one
which then gradually led to his hatred
of all might and hero society as a whole
therefore with environment being such an
important factor
let's imagine on that crucial day when
myriad was saved
what if the hero who saved him was just
stuck in traffic or something
now i know what you're thinking if no
hero showed up then doesn't that mean he
just dies
and in the real world yes you would
probably be right but
in this case i refer you to my hero
academia vigilantes
in this spin-off manga there was a
character called oberoshirokumo
who was literally created to be a
myrial-like character for this spin-off
shirakumo himself suffered an accident
that supposedly killed him
but after being taken to the morgue dr
garaki was able to remodel him
until he became the highly intelligent
nomu known as kurogiri
he was unlike any nomu we'd seen before
and that he was fully capable of
independent thought
and regular human conversation also his
original cloud quirk was remodeled
significantly
into this just amazing teleportation
ability in the same way that shirakuma
was believed to have died
what if a similar series of events had
happened to a young mirio tagata
as a quick theory maybe if a hero never
showed up miria would have nearly
drowned and been taken to the hospital
once there he'd be in the hands of dr
garaki who is apparently the only doctor
in the mighty academia universe
garaki would realize the potential of
myrio's permeation quirk
perhaps by looking through his file or
something like that it's not a quirk
that graggy could just steal because
as we've seen you know permeation
requires intense practice from the user
so instead of stealing the quirk it's
better to let the boy keep it and
practice and train with it instead
because of this gracky would have three
options at this point
number one he could let mirio die and
turn him into a
style nomu however the one downside of
this is that because miriam was like
what about five years old
if he died and was turned into a nomu
he'd likely stay the same
bite-sized height that he was option
number two though
he could keep mario alive but fake his
death somehow
that way miriam's family would think he
died but the doctor could secretly
abduct him and give him the winter
soldier
brainwashing treatment like i said with
the potential of permeation
mirio would be an invaluable asset that
they could mould into a bodyguard for
all for one and shigaraki
naturally the third and final option is
that dr garaki actually does his job of
being a doctor
and saves mario returns him back to his
family and that's the end of it
but come on guys it's dr graki that is
not happening
for the purpose of this video let's
assume the doctor takes the second
option
and abducts a young muriel as a kid he
could have done a bunch of things to
fake mario's death so
i'm gonna go with this option levillion
would be given a few supporting quirks
on top of permeation
even without being a nomu he can still
have his body modified to handle
multiple quirks so yeah this is fine
being the mastermind that he is i mean
we even saw it with kurogiri
the doctor knows which quarks go best
with which so this kind of made me
wonder
what type of abilities would be added to
a quirk like permeation
the first power that came to my mind at
least was adding the ability to fly
being able to fly away whilst permeating
through different things
you can't be captured like no one's
gonna hold you if you can become
intangible and fly away
by adding flight this would give his
punches a lot more momentum
and it also means that he'd have
incredible speed in addition to being
untouchable
another quirk that i also think would be
a good fit for permeation
is invisibility it would just make mirio
the ultimate evil ghost
unlike her gakurei though this would be
a transformation quirk
rather than a mutation quirk so if myria
wants to he can be visible or invisible
it's completely up to him
it makes sense for mario to have a
power-like invisibility
because when he's permeating lights
going through him everything's going
through him
but i mean as we've seen you know when
he permeates we still see him butt naked
there so uh
yeah maybe adding invisibility would be
a natural fit for a character like this
the timeline would change pretty
drastically before this happened for
starters during the battle at camino
reverse lamilian could have easily
turned the tide in favor of the villains
when bakago began to escape how creepy
and disheartening would it have been
if at this moment we see kachan being
dramatically yanked back out of thin air
and brought back to the battlefield by
just a completely invisible person
or hell if all for one was still
captured muriel could
genuinely break him out of tartarus
single-handedly
now when we look at regular miriam's
personality he's someone who's
incredibly confident
during the overhaul arc we saw that he
pressed on ahead in front of all the
heroes
and tried to find erie single-handedly
and at ua
it was him who proposed the idea of
fighting the entirety of class 1a by
himself
on top of that he's more than willing to
sacrifice himself
or do things that aren't in his own best
interest to benefit other people
this selflessness isn't just limited to
sacrificing his own quirk
but it was also shown when he turned
down deku's offer to receive one for all
because it would have caused deku pain
as well how exactly does a selfless and
confident guy like that
fit into the league of villains and how
much would his personality change
as a bad guy assuming that garaki
doesn't mess with his head too much
this is what i think would happen due to
his body modifications
the million black's confidence would be
through the roof even more so than his
regular self
in the main timeline like i said he
whooped class 1a in his normal form
so a modified evil version of this
character with multiple quirks
i mean during the usj attack he might
have just dived in headfirst
and killed the entire class also because
he can turn invisible
it's possible isabella just wouldn't
know where he is so he couldn't erase
mirio's quirks
he's only a couple years younger than
shiguraki so i guess in this timeline
shiggy might actually have a friend
growing up
besides the nomu and fully grown adults
self-sacrifice is also an important
aspect of being a bodyguard
and we've seen that machia and kirigiri
they have an intense dedication to all
for one and sugaraki
the same would also have to be true for
mario he'd be sure to do whatever he
could to protect his superiors
even if that means dying one thing i
would say though is that
if him and shiguraki grew up together i
mean like i said they're quite close in
age
so it wouldn't even be like a forced
relationship like they would genuinely
be
friends and muriel would be more than
willing to put his life on the line for
him
who knows maybe shiguraki himself
wouldn't be as vicious as he is in the
present day
if he had a friend like mirio lastly the
final point i wanted to make was
what do you guys think the million would
stand for in this scenario when he's a
villain
as a hero he wanted to save a million
people although it was never stated why
that particular number if we flip the
script uh i guess it would mean he wants
to
eradicate a million heroes although i
mean we don't know how many heroes there
are in japan
it does have a big population though i
don't know if there'd be a million
heroes
and i also don't think he would just do
kill a million people like
that's just lame like why do you want to
kill a million people we need to have
some motivations here so
let me know down in the comments what
would the million in the million or
lavillion stand for i'm curious to know
your thoughts because i couldn't really
wrap my head around this
one anyway people those are my thoughts
on what if lamillion was a villain
if you've not seen it already then do be
sure to check out this other video i did
on what if overhaul was a hero and until
next time
peace out